yeah all right let's get started
first as a reminder this lunch is a
little shorter
so the afternoon session starts at 1 14
so two o'clock last year
the first stop we have dao uh your from
my friends to tell us about decision
making
under miss calibration
okay good uh can you hear me
okay perfect uh okay so first let me say
that i'm very sorry that i can't be uh
with you in person
um but it's actually nice seeing and
hearing some familiar faces and voices
um okay so
for those that i don't know my name is
gal
i'm a student at the weitzman institute
and today i want to tell you about this
kind of recent and
somewhat ongoing work decision making
under miscalibration
okay and this is joined with a guy who
spoke before me
okay good so
right as kind of the background sentence
that you've heard a million times
machine learning is used to inform
consequential decisions about
individuals
in this talk i have binary decisions in
mind
and specifically a setting in which i
have a bunch of these binary decisions
and these are often not kind of
optimized end-to-end
right think of a setting where i have
multiple decisions that have significant
overlap between them so for this like
really silly example i want to show ads
on google so maybe one binary decision
is whether i show
an ad on the right another binary
decision as whether i show an ad on the
left right like there's a lot in common
for these different decisions
okay so the setup that we're going to
talk about and formalized is in some
sense
i have one single model
of the world of ads whatever that then
informs multiple downstream decisions
okay and i didn't mention but please uh
interrupt me with questions at any point
or at the end if you prefer
okay good so
let's start by making this formal um i
have an
individual with features
x living in some feature space rd
this is then transformed into a
prediction so for example here i have p
of x which is in the interval 0 1 maybe
predicting some risk of heart attack in
10 years
and then i i have a setting in mind
where i then use this prediction to make
different decisions so for example
whether
the individual would undergo some kind
of diagnostic test is the first example
and
maybe
whether they would receive a certain
treatment etc okay and these are binary
decisions
so in some sense this defines these two
stages the modeling part of the problem
where i fit this
in this case this risk prediction model
and then the decision-making part or
kind of post-processing or transforming
this estimate of risk into potentially
actionable decisions
okay so i'll be focused more on this
decision-making or post-processing part
okay so just to to have this uh set up
in mind some of this notation came up
also in guy's talk
so i'm going to use p star to denote
kind of the bayes optimal predictor or
in this case the true probability of
some binary outcome y conditioned on the
features x
and let's for now just think of one of
these binary problems for example
whether to have the individual though
undergo some kind of screening test
okay and this raises kind of this simple
problem of uh given that i have a
predictor p which is some estimate of p
star
how do i then use p to decide which
individuals to screen
and actually when p
this predictor is exactly p star
turns out that the answer to this
question is is both simple and very well
understood basically the optimal thing
for me to do is to take the prediction
of risk and
basically decide kind of the on the
binary treatment uh if and only if this
p of x exceeds a certain threshold j
star
okay so j star is going to be like a
prime uh
actor in this uh in this talk so
we'll revisit it again and again
and i want to make kind of three
immediate comments about this j star
first of all i sometimes refer to it as
the therapeutic threshold this was uh
coined in this early work from 1975
the second thing is as we'll see
kind of later
this j star depends on the cost
structure of the binary decision problem
in this case this screening test so
think the relative costs are of false
positives as opposed to true positives
for example um right so if you think
about kind of thresholding at 0.9 right
essentially this conveys some sort of
information specifically that false
positives are quite costly for you so
you want to be conservative
um
and finally and this is actually an
important remark i stated this result as
being true when p is exactly p star but
it's actually also true in that j star
is the optimal threshold to use it's
also true when p is perfectly calibrated
with respect to p star
okay so i don't have a formal definition
here but kind of think of it as if the
data distribution is such that p star
is the
true conditional risk then p kind of has
a calibration error of exactly zero with
respect to this data distribution
um
okay good so i'm storming ahead
so right after guys talk the first thing
that naturally comes to your mind is
okay
what happens when predictors are
miscalibrated as
we know that they sometimes are so at
least before you
work very hard to calibrate them
um okay so one kind of immediate
observation that's simple but actually
fundamental here is that when the
predictor is not perfectly calibrated
right it can even have some very mild
but slight miscalibration
then actually still doing this strategy
of thresholding at jstar could be really
kind of sub-optimal or clearly not the
thing that you would want to do
and
i have here this intuitive example that
i'll also revisit and make formal a bit
later but think of kind of a very simple
setting where for the entire population
t star is at one minus alpha for some
small alpha
and p the prediction is at one okay so
obviously a toy example this gives rise
to exactly alpha miscalibration
and now consider
a decision problem for which j star this
optimal threshold is also very very high
it's close to one specifically it's
larger than one minus alpha in
particular this means that false
positives for this problem are very very
costly
okay so if you now think of taking p of
x and thresholding at j star
right it essentially treats everyone
because everyone has a prediction of one
and that's above the threshold
in particular it means that
as a binary classifier the fraction of
false positives that i'm going to have
by the definition of p star
is exactly alpha in expectation
and since this decision problem is such
that false positives are very costly
then i'm going to experience very high
loss here
okay so at least on an intuitive level
and i'm not really taking into account
at least properly
this potential for alpha miscalibration
which could be very costly
so with this kind of intuitive example
in mind
um we think that this raises a very
fundamental question which is how do you
translate
potentially miscalibrated predictions
into binary decisions
and i'll give like a an overview of kind
of our contributions here and and i'll
go into a bit more depth in uh soon
but basically we propose a new solution
concept for for how to go about this
question um as i'll discuss it's a
distribution free
quantity so like it doesn't depend on
the underlying distribution
we refer to this as the regret
minimizing threshold j
and i've kind of emphasized here in this
notation that it's a function of both j
star which is kind of the optimal
threshold under
alpha equals zero or perfect calibration
and alpha which is this kind of
anticipated level of miscalibration
and
we then proceed to actually give closed
form expressions for how this regret
minimizing threshold looks like and kind
of the
the spoiler here is that there are
actually interesting cases where
this is not exactly j star
so in some
informal sense you really should be
taking into account errors in the way
that you make predictions
um okay so before i delve into these uh
exciting uh details
i do want to give kind of a bird's-eye
view of where i see these types of
questions and and also how did they
relate to to concepts
in causality
so basically the the starting point i
think for me and partly why i'm excited
about this line of
kind of research is that
first of all this distinction between
modeling and decision making i think is
very fundamental right it's not
particular to this kind of setup that
i've described here where the model is a
an estimate of risk um right it's i
think equally valid or relevant when the
model is a causal model right like we
use causal models to make
decisions
and i also think that it's often the
case that if i give you a perfect model
whether it's a causal model or a risk
model whatever then it's actually quite
clear how to make optimal decisions
right like the post-processing function
here i called it f star it's it's often
uh clear how to how to do it um but this
raises this question of okay how bad can
this composition of f star and my
predictor p or my model p be
when p is not guaranteed to be the
perfect model it's in some sense only my
kind of best approximation of this
perfect model okay taking into account
what computational issues sample
complexity issues things that we know
that we are going to run into in
practice um
okay so i think this raises this
fundamental question of
when can we ever do better by making
decisions differently and then what are
these different functions f that are not
f star
how do they look like how do we go about
choosing them
okay so this is like my
my pitch for why it's relevant for you
and potentially interesting even if you
hate uh risk prediction models uh and uh
everything that's to do with them
okay uh maybe questions at this point
okay good
okay so i'll i'll make the setup uh a
bit more formal so that we can actually
go into some definitions so this is
everything that i've already said we
have a binary outcome y and a feature
space x
we have this p star
and we're then going to
use estimates of this p star to inform
decisions
and
this result that i talked about
before from
this therapeutic threshold basically
says that if you give me a binary
decision
that has some utilities given by
you of false negatives false positives
true positives and true negatives
then
if what you're interested in is kind of
maximizing expected utility then what
you should do is you should take p star
and you should threshold it at a j star
that satisfies this equation that i have
here
and it's a very simple derivation that
i'm not showing
and i also
want to mention so i see that we have
some like actual clinicians in in the
crowd so maybe i need to be careful but
by what i'm saying but i'll say it and
you can correct me
but i think people
are actually kind of uh involved in this
exercise of coming up with these
utilities
and then deriving the optimal thresholds
for kind of recommending treatment here
i gave one numerical example that i
found for for colonoscopy and actually
in the paper they go through the
kind of details of how they came up with
these numbers okay so it's something
that i think is really
kind of done in practice a lot
okay
so
i want to talk about this um concept of
decision curve analysis this was uh
introduced by vickers and elkin in 2005.
um basically the way i like to think
about it is
kind of a simplified version of this
full utility analysis that i talked
about before where you actually have to
specify these four
parameters
so basically the starting point is this
equation or relationship that we had
before
um right and now what we're doing is
let's call the numerator p and the
denominator l so you can also think of p
as kind of the benefit from a true
positive in the sense that it's this
difference in utility for making a
positive as opposed to a negative
prediction
conditioned on this population of people
that actually have y equals
1 the condition and similarly l is the
harm from making a false positive
prediction
so what they do is they say okay let's
just fix one of these values at one say
p at one
and now we have this
uh immediate relationship between the
harm from uh false positive and
this uh
odds ratio of j star
okay and basically if you
look at this equation
without kind of the details but it
immediately gives right it kind of says
that i can think of the optimal
threshold j star
as also an equivalent parametrization of
the decision problem itself right under
these simplified uh utility assumptions
okay so specifically in the rest of the
talk whenever i want to
index the binary decision that i'm
actually talking about i'll use j star
to denote this and the reason i'll do it
is because of this relationship or
equivalent view
of the decision in the sense of the cost
structure and j star as related in this
equation
okay so i hope at at least on a high
level that's understood
so going back to this decision curve
analysis basically a fundamental
question
right like that a clinician for example
would want to ask is okay you gave me a
predictor i want to use it for a binary
decision problem j star
how good is how
to use p for this problem
and the the proposal uh in this uh in
this line of work is to define this
concept of net benefit
so specifically it's it's kind of a
and
not a nice looking equation but what's
written here is actually very simple
the net benefit of using p
for a decision problem j star
is basically a weighted average of the
true positives and the false positive
predictions that you're going to make if
you'll be using the binary
classifier that's obtained by taking p
and thresholding it at j star okay and
kind of specifically um this is with the
weights of this combination
given by pnl from the previous slide
okay so the way i like to think about
this is right like the reason it's
called the net benefit is in some sense
it talks about uh it quantifies the
effective
uh rate of true positives effective in
the sense of kind of discounting for the
false positive predictions as they are
valued in terms of true positives
okay so if this is the first time
you've seen this it might be a bit
confusing the details are not
necessarily as crucial as much as you
can just think of this as kind of a you
know if you're used to machine learning
and loss functions then think of this as
some way to quantify um how how good are
the loss of the predictors
okay so
if you've believed me until now then you
might have
like this other question in mind so
suppose i tell you that a predictor p
has a net benefit of some value say
0.1 right like what does this value mean
is it high is it low right like if you
if you're a clinician then does 0.1
justify actually using this predictor to
make uh decisions
um so the the proposal
um here which is
kind of very
simple but it takes a step in this
direction
is to define the clinical utility of a
predictor with respect to a task as the
net benefit after
kind of discounting or
removing the maximum between the net
benefit of two other things you could do
which is to threshold p
at either a value of zero or a value of
one
okay basically these are kind of
treating everyone or treating no one um
policies
and right like the way the way you can
think about it is
these are things that i could have done
i could have implemented
also if i didn't have the predictor at
all so in particular doing worse than
these strategies is like a huge
red flag
um so maybe like a a simple
sanity check and if this quantity is is
positive then it's like uh a measure of
utility basically
okay good and
i think one of the reasons why this
approach has become
really really popular in this area of
clinical decision making is that it
lends itself to these very like simple
and intuitive
plots or graphs so
this is what a decision curve
looks like so here what we have on the
x-axis is basically
j star
so the different
thresholds that represent as i've
mentioned different
decisions binary decision problems the
y-axis is the net benefit
the solid line that's fixed at a value
of zero
is the net benefit of the strategy of
taking p and thresholding it at one so
basically treating no one and that's why
it's constant at zero
the
gray line that's kind of starting high
and then decreasing monotonically
is the net benefit of treating everyone
again the reason why it's decreasing is
that as jstar
increases the cost of making a false
positive prediction increases so this
strategy becomes kind of worse and worse
and the other two lines the remaining
two lines are basically just two uh
specific models so this is also giving
you like a nice way to to compare models
and something that should be very
obvious even for some someone that
doesn't know like anything about machine
learning is that you can really see from
this graph
exactly the range of uh thresholds for
which
kind of using this predictive model give
actually gives you clinical utility okay
so if you're a clinician and you're
working on uh i don't know like a
diagnostic test where you want to use it
with a threshold of say 0.4 because
that's a structure of of the test the
the utility is there then you see that
okay this model has clinical utility for
this value
okay so that's just like uh
uh three minutes uh maybe more uh
introduction to this area
okay so let's try to
just wrap up this notation i promise i
don't have any uh additional uh these
types of definitions
so in the beginning of the talk i talked
about these models right like i
made the distinction between models and
decision making so here as i've
mentioned models are just predictions of
risk
in terms of evaluating performance of
models the loss that i'm thinking about
here is calibration error
the downstream tasks that i have in mind
are basically all the different
thresholds from
one to
from one over m to m minus one over m
and here m is some parameter that's kind
of controlling the granularity of these
uh
different tasks
performance in terms of decisions right
in terms of binary classifiers is then
measured using this
negative of the clinical utility as i've
described
decision making or how i translate
predictions into decisions is by
thresholding so this defines kind of a
class of of different thresholds
and optimal decision making which is
just to remind you it's the
the decision making or the
post-processing that i would apply to a
perfect model right a model that has
lost exactly zero
that's j star or this therapeutic
threshold
okay so hopefully
if you even if you missed some of the
details then this uh kind of high-level
picture is fairly clear
okay
okay you can definitely hear me right
okay
okay um
no because i you asked a lot of
questions in guys talk i'm not saying
anything just uh just wanted to make
sure
okay
[Music]
okay so i want to
kind of just mention revisit this
negative example that way that i i gave
in the beginning right so what do i mean
by negative example this is basically a
case where i start out with the
predictor a predictor that has
fairly low loss right so it's not
perfect it doesn't have a loss of zero
but it has a low loss some alpha that's
actually quite close to zero
and then i want to reason about the loss
of the binary classifier that's obtained
by thresholding p at j star
and basically my my point is that
this can actually scale like alpha times
m where m is this granularity parameter
from before
and specifically this uh like lower
bound
like ridiculously simple lower bound
um is obtained by taking j star to be
very very close to one as i've had
before and you can go through the math
of calculating the clinical utility here
write the losses just the negative of
the clinical utility
um basically the net benefit of the
model and the net benefit of
thresholding at zero so these two
quantities
are essentially the same right they're
the same because
for when the predictions are one for
everyone then it's you're just treating
everyone so these things are the same
and just by substituting here the
the odds ratio you get to a value that's
exactly one minus alpha n
and the net benefit of treating no one
is always zero so here we have one minus
alpha m
so the negative of this is alpha m minus
one which can be
very high when m is large
okay so this is the the example from
before
so
what are the the takeaways right the
point is that naively using j star even
when the miscalibration is mild could be
bad
this also suggests kind of two natural
things that you could do right you could
try to make alpha smaller right you
could do your best to really really
calibrate the model
right but at the end of the day some
amount of miscalibration on the target
distribution is unavoidable
just due to generalization
and also you could make m smaller but
then again kind of the ability to make
granular distinctions is is usually
something that you want to maintain
so this motivates kind of this shift in
attention to a third knob which is the
mechanism by which we translate
predictions to decisions
so specifically we ask given some value
of alpha that's the anticipated
miscalibration and given a particular
decision problem j star
which other threshold should we be using
okay and as i've
as i've mentioned the
kind of our proposal which uh i think
you can kind of say good things about
but there are also natural kind of
extensions or other routes you could
take
is to use what we call this regret
minimizing threshold okay so basically
for every threshold i'm defining a costs
function
which is the maximal regret okay and
here
i'll say what regret is in a second the
maximum is taking over kind of any
possible
target distribution
and any possible predictor p
as long as the miscalibration of p with
respect to this target distribution is
at most alpha
right so i'm kind of i'm talking about a
setting that is pretty worst kc in the
sense that
i'm not willing to assume anything about
the distribution that i would end up
encountering except that my predictor is
at most alpha miscalibrated on
and then the the regret of
using a threshold g
with this predictor p
is basically the net benefit obtained by
thresholding p
at this threshold j minus kind of the
the net benefit of thresholding p
at the best threshold right like the
best threshold in hindsight um
right and
if you remember this notion of clinical
utility then
you should see that this is like a
generalization of it in the sense that
for clinical utility we
competed in some sense only against two
particular thresholds zero and one treat
all and treat none and here i'm saying
okay i also want to kind of measure
myself against
every possible threshold in particular
the best one
technically this solves a lot of like
annoying
problems that come up when you want to
use this notion of clinical creativity
indirectly
okay so this is um
at least
at a high level i think uh this is the
concept of regret minimization that we
work with
in principle right like it's a it's a
non-trivial kind of min-max optimization
problem the solution is not a priori
clear
what we do in this work and these are
details that i won't go into is we
obtain close form expressions for
exactly how this threshold looks like
when miscalibration is measured kind of
using different popular notions
specifically we look at the maximum
calibration error and the expected
calibration error
and i've plotted here
on the right uh kind of how
j
differs from j star so
you can see that in the middle right
like for problems with
an intermediate value of j star then j
is exactly j star but when you move uh
towards the edges then
j is in some sense a more conservative
version of jstar
okay so
please the takeaway that i want you to
have in mind at this point is that when
we encounter decision problems that are
kind of significantly asymmetric in that
their optimal threshold is near the
edges
then the optimal behavior at least in
the sense of regret minimization is to
kind of take a hedgier bets and take a
conservative version of jstar
okay so
i think i'll take uh maybe two more
minutes just to describe a bit of
empirical validation of these
theoretical results
so basically we look at
two
settings where kind of miscalibration is
naturally occurring
the first is when we learn on small data
so as i've mentioned you know even if
we're calibrated on our small data we
expect to see some
generalization error and the second is
kind of the setup of uh
subgroup evaluation so i'm evaluating on
subgroups that the model was not
actually trained on
this constitutes a form of distribution
shift so we also expect to see some
miscalibration there
pretty soon specifically
just to give you like a touch of the
results so
for the small data
intuitively what what i'm doing here is
i'm taking i'm training a model on small
number of examples so here increasing
from 400 all the way to
1600
and i'm looking at the difference in
clinical utility
from
using j star and using my proposed uh
threshold uh the regret minimizing
threshold j
and here i've plotted kind of uh j with
respect to
different values of alpha 0.05 0.1 and
0.2
then what you
what you should take away from from this
graph is basically that
kind of
when
when the number of training example is
small so we really the predictor that
you end up learning really is somewhat
miscalibrated
so you should actually be it's a good
idea that you're hedging your bets and
using this uh conservative threshold j
and indeed there's an improvement in the
clinical utility
okay but also expected is as the number
of training examples increases so in
some sense you're being
overly conservative right like you're
you you're losing clinical utility when
there's actually no miscalibration so
then it becomes that using j
our proposed threshold is actually worse
than using jsta okay so this just speaks
to the fact that you know this is
appropriate to the extent that you can
correctly anticipate uh miscalibration
okay and the other uh the other setup
is basically i'm taking one of the
kind of features that are actually
relevant to this uh to this task
i'm removing it completely during
training time
i'm training a predictor learning a
predictor and then i'm looking i'm
evaluating on the two subgroups that are
formed by this binary feature so
everyone that has this binary feature
set at zero and everyone that has the
binary feature set at one
and this this ends up creating some
miscalibration right this is uh to be
expected
and here are the decision curves from
this is from the middle rows from using
j star and the
previous the bottom row is from using
j
our regret minimizing threshold okay and
you can indeed see that like there is
some miscalibration going on here in the
low probabilities for one of the
subgroups this ends up being costly
being actually creating clinical harm
right in this area we are worse than the
baseline of treating no one and
the
regret minimizing threshold kind of
anticipates this concern and is
conservative and says okay i'm just not
going to treat anyone
there
okay so this is just to give you a sense
of the
results uh right like the the takeaways
basically that
we think that there are actually
practical settings in which this can
improve the clinical utility
okay good so uh this brings me to my uh
summary so
just repeating kind of things that i
have already said basically when
predictions
are used to inform decisions which i
think happens maybe more than we're
actually
taking into account when we're doing all
this machine learning
then
if you anticipate errors in the
prediction
then it's actually the right thing to do
in some formal sense
we go with this proposed solution
concept of regret minimizing threshold
we show that there are actually
interesting cases where it's not the
usual threshold that you would use
and using it can actually improve
clinical utility um
in terms of like
perspectives thoughts other things that
i think you could uh you could think
about in this context um
first of all like other settings right
like i've described this clinical
decision making but i'm sure that there
are other instances
um
most notably like other solution
concepts right this is the thing i've
presented here is
it's very worst casey in its nature
because of the fact that it's
distribution
it's distribution-free
okay i'm kind of coming up with a
threshold that you should use that is
the best threshold irrespective of
actually the predictor that you have at
hand
so i think that's really like one very
concrete question
uh it's also to it's also natural to
think i think about stronger guarantees
for example
what about regret with respect to a
richer class of threshold maybe
randomized thresholds
um
and finally right like at a very very
high level right like is there some
general theory for for optimal decision
making specifically in the air in this
regime of
errors in my modeling stage and how to
optimally take these into account
um
okay good so that's it
for today
um if the goal of a model a prediction
or causal model is to make a binary
decision i'm
asked about why
you would approach that with this kind
of two stage first fit the model then
make the decision framework
instead of just
applying a loss function to the decision
itself which i think would be similar to
like um
methods to learn optimal treatment rules
and the causal world and in particular
it seems
at a very
abstract level that that would allow you
to
have the regret depend on the predictors
instead of
this worst case
scenario where you've pre-processed or
sorry where you fit a model condensed
everything down to a single dimension
and are looking at regret
on that
yeah yeah it's a good question so
i i'm not saying this is kind of this is
the way to think about every possible
binary decision right in particular as
i've mentioned in the beginning there
are a lot of cases where you kind of
optimize i called it end to end right
like you optimize directly for this
binary target
um
i think my main point is
in many cases we're not just talking
about one binary problem in isolation
right like there's the there's going to
be the wonderful talk by noah and nom i
think later right like if you're a big
healthcare decision and you can a
healthcare provider and you're faced
with a lot of different predictions
about individuals that you need to make
then there are clear
kind of benefits from figuring out the
shared component of these uh of these
problems so just even from a
computational perspective so my
um i don't know like from what i see i
think this is a natural thing that's
actually occurring in a lot of cases
this distinction between modeling and
decision making i'm by no means saying
that this is how you should think about
every task and this is like a very high
level of abstraction that i think we
should be
we should be thinking about right like
even
algorithms that are designed to output
predictions right like some part of my
point is that we can't just forget about
everything once i give you the
prediction right like it's not the end
of the day
so um i'm curious if you thought at all
about um
extending this to sort of an individual
specific threshold
so if you can you can you sort of uh
think about
if you had for instance confidence
intervals or some sort of
sense for an individual
uh their miscalibration can you
use that to
base your threshold
yeah so i haven't uh thought about it
yet i think it's very natural once you
start thinking about like these types of
subgroup miscalibrations right like
different maybe we anticipate different
levels of miscalibration for different
subgroups for example based on their um
fraction or mass in the population and
then we want to kind of be
uh different
in how conservative we are for different
uh individuals so yeah it's a great
point but not one that i thought
you